I think we can go ahead and get started
are you guys able to hear me okay you
speak up a little bit more okay so it's
I'm showing that it's now it's just past
11:30 so I think we'll get started and
as a way of introduction i'm blake lhasa
Roth I'm one of the faculty in the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology and welcome again
to the on informatics series and this
particular one is our clinical Grand
Rounds and so just a couple of quick
items and then I'm gonna introduce our
speaker for today first of all for those
of you that want to ask questions that
are in our audience I understand this is
also streaming but for those of you that
are present today don't forget that we
we love your feedback and your insights
we also want to capture them for
posterity so please don't forget that
when you're asking a question press the
device in front of you and hold it while
you're speaking that way it also
projects and it gets recorded so that we
have those questions for our distance
audience and the other thing I think is
important to point out is that we have
this is actually also you can collect
CME credit for this and so if you're
inclined to collect CME credit for this
please contact Lynch Wahby
at schwa BL at OHSU edu because I
believe there's a very brief quiz a
brutal punishing quiz that you just take
afterwards and then they will collect
that information then you get a signed
CME credit for which is lovely so with
that I'm very excited to present our
colleague today in Oh Kim dr. Kim and as
a way of background dr. Kim actually has
a really interesting background he
started out in music he was actually at
Brown University and I understand that
he actually studied or Orchestra as well
as trombone so I suspect at some point
that's going to wend it's it's going to
wind its way into informatics I'm not
sure how just yet but I I trust it'll be
exciting and then after that he went to
the the Medical College of Georgia to
get his degree in medicine and then
following that he actually started
studying emergency medicine and he
completed his residency at New York
Presbyterian in Manhattan which is
actually an
affiliative Columbia University since
then he's now joined us in the clinical
informatics fellowship here and had
actually completed a number of decision
support projects at the VA just in the
last semester so today he's going to be
joining us to talk a little bit about a
little bit of background information on
clinical decision support systems and
then tying that into a real-world
example of how he actually designs and
decision support for with the intent to
implement at the Portland VA so with
that I welcome in how kin thank you so
much for joining us
good yeah so dr. mohan thought this
would be good dry run for me so i
because i have to present on the order
menu next week so i would welcome any
comments or improvements that i can have
especially on the order menu part so
just kind of what we're going to talk
about today a little bit about just a
little brief introduction on clinical
decision support and CPOE because as
many of the de maiz postdoc postgrads
here have probably heard a lot a lot a
lot about CPOE and CVS they don't want
me to hear any more but just a brief
introduction and then a little taxonomy
on coalition support and then the actual
order menu at the VA so why like a
little bit of why we have culture
support part of that is one of the pain
main impetus is the Institute of
Medicine in 2000 came out with the fact
that we're just making a lot of errors
all the time like half our errors from
adverse drug events are at the time of
ordering we're spending maybe two
million dollars per Hospital per year
because of these errors that we're
making but also why does it relate to
see yes it really CVS because a lot of
times
look those errors can be avoided if we
had information at the elbows when we as
clinicians are putting the orders in and
in the sense of like drug allergies drug
drug interactions and things like that
and also we need to then use that
information to make sure that would
continue to not make as many errors
because I think it's impossible to not
have no to have no errors but hopefully
we can have left
and then so how do we do that so part of
the way we do that is we take that
information and we kind of put it in
front of the physician in the EHR but
there's a lot of information just even
in 1976 when McDonald they just found
for them before the internet for all of
that there's just there was already way
too much information there were already
way too many papers
trials and different things going on and
so we have to somehow take all of that
information and put it at the elbow and
make it useful and not just have hey
here's the million things that you can
read about to figure out how to make
sure that you don't screw up so what
basically is so it again it's basically
making sure that when the clinician is
putting the order in or doing whatever
they're doing in electronic health
record that they have their information
that tool at the elbow and how to come
up with what you use is kind of the Venn
diagram you've maybe seen a lot is
taking the evidence taking different
constraints like whether it's laws or
like what drugs are FDA approved or not
and the patient-physician relationship
and like what the physician thinks is
going on and when you put those together
to find kind of the balance of all those
to find out what you want to use for
your clinical decision support the
clinical decision port support usually
sits on top of the EHR and that's we're
just going to talk briefly about CPOE
and that's basically the method or the
way that a clinician can enter orders
that's
some examples it's just the way so that
instead of having to type in from blank
like metoprolol twenty-five milligrams p
o-- that you can have Motoko already in
there because you've selected it and it
has a list of whatever metallic um two
five ten twenty five milligrams
instead of having to choose between
milliliters milligrams grams and
everything just have everything kind of
a little less cognitive overhead for the
position at time of watering so less
chance of error so an advantage this EPO
again the main advantage when we first
started using electronic health records
is first and foremost not having to
worry about handwriting and
transcription errors there's pre
configured order sets first even speed
if you're omitting a patient for chest
pain you don't have to go search for the
CVC the coag's and the troponin if
you're doing a pre-op order set you
don't have to worry about doing pain
medications and IV orders they're all
just kind of prefilled and you can click
yeah yeah
so that's Oh so he just asked like who
who bundles these order sets and who it
depends on the hospital and the
structure so if there's a robust
informatics program the usually
informatics group does if there's not at
for instance at Columbia where there
wasn't a robust informatics program
that's integrated with the hospital they
have a very good research group but it's
not in the art it's not very fully well
integrated in the operations part and so
for example they wanted to have it so
that for was it or low-risk chest pain
you've had two troponin Xand you had two
EKGs within 30 minutes and that was the
order set and it was uh you know a CBC
etc and that was done by the emergency
department there was just a physician
who was part of the administration as
part of qi who like we're gonna do that
with without kind of going about
usability going about like who is it
going to affect who's gonna use it is
this the best way to do it is it's not
the best way to do it and so they just
did it through their emergency
department and that's just how you did
it but if if you're at a place with a
more robust clinical informatics program
that usually the in fermentations with
consultation with cardiologists with the
emergency physicians with nursing with
the lab techs to see like is this the
best lab is this the right way to put
that in and that
so some literature support for clinical
decision support so there's no like 100%
that at least in evidence-based medicine
that clinical judgment support is the
best and be-all-end-all there's been
studies before that or systematic
reviews that showed yes it's very good
there's been a couple that were like and
it's it works it kinda doesn't work just
I just want to show you a more recent
one 2014 by I don't know no crown same
MO hormone I doubt and they took did a
systematic review up and I think 2013 or
2012 and from those they had about 3,000
studies but from those 3,000 dates they
pared it down to 16 of them to check for
mortality to see if conclusions report
actually for better or for worse
affected mortality and they found there
was there was no change adding a
clinical decision support system to an
EHR or comparing a EHR with clinical
distance report to one without
clinicians report there was no change in
mortality like benefit and then when
they did a morbidity outcome with nine
other studies they found that there was
maybe some association but it wasn't a
clear-cut like definite yes it's much
better having clinical support at least
evidence-based medicine so when
designing clinical support what are
different ways to go about doing it
there are many different ways like or
fluff I can't pronounce the name has
like the right five rights the right
person the right information there's
again there's many different ways but
one of the ways that I like to think
about it is Bates and came out and from
Brigham's they studied a bunch of clubs
afford to figure out you know what what
do people really need or want when it
comes to clones to support and one of
the first things that really pops up is
speed is everything for clinicians like
you're already working a long day if
you're a surgeon you you're you're there
at five o'clock you're rounding on your
patients then you're going to or you
don't have time so it speed is
everything
also it's - as said before closer
supports making sure that the
information is at the elbow there they
don't have to go hunt for it you don't
have to go to another somewhere else
wherever that may be
website or wherever to find that
information so that you can have that
information at point of care to
understand the workflow so that it's not
again in some weird place where the
physician has to go outside of their way
to find it which it's all kind of
sometimes comes down to speed and of
course usability other things to think
about is that it can't be too
complicated as with like this the
seventh point and like what that's why
kind of Google is so successful is like
about your lesser off point out to be
earlier instead of having it all complex
and and having out there in the front
Google is very powerful it can do a lot
of stuff and it can search for anything
and everything if you know how to search
for it and use the terms but the
interface is simple so that you you
don't get put off by it and so have
simplicity have it's easier to modify
them to cancel because if you I don't
know if you for those of us been in EHRs
if you have to cancel sometimes you have
to go to the very beginning you have to
then click the order button which pulls
the order up then find the medication
then go to the medication and then put
in the dose and then press ok
whereas if you can just modify that at
that point where you can just change the
po2 IV at that point because you click
the wrong thing on the second step it's
much quicker it's much easier other
things is to make sure that you're
studying what you've implemented that's
just because you've been implemented and
you've talked to all the stakeholders
got all the by and did the usability and
you think that it's gonna work and
you've worked through the workflow this
doesn't mean that it will work so to
make sure that if you've implemented a
clinical judgment support that you study
a to make sure to see if what its impact
is see if it's any good
see if it's making it's actually
improving care and decreasing errors
we're just kind of again going back to
what all this was about of having
conquered your support decreasing errors
it is going back to kind of simplicity
making sure that you're not having too
much of information that you don't need
at the time that your physician or
whoever is putting any orders or putting
in the notes just some other things the
kind of main point of this slide is that
it's not just the technology but
sometimes the hospital the department
the section the group the clinic will
come and say hey like make us a tool or
a widget or something to fix you know
too many patients coming in at once and
sometimes it's sometimes it is a tool or
widget that will help and sometimes it's
not for them it's a workflow issue
sometimes the personnel issue some have
an education issue so it's not that
technology is the be-all cure-all so
have there are different tax on amis of
c.d.s it's just one of the random ones
that I picked that I liked it was done
by Adam Wright fitted nicely these are
the ones that came up with how they came
up with this they went to multiple sites
it was like I don't know the exact
number it's about seven large
institutions some were epic somewhere
Cerner Inc one or two or homegrown and
they tried to survey the sites and see
what they had when it came to Clinton
support and they took all the different
kinds of clinical support they had and
put them in and then from looking at
those place made these five categories
so just to tell you a little about each
category some medication dosing support
that that can range from a lot of
different things and one of those things
can be just having default dosing so
that you don't have to memorize what
ibuprofen is or if it's been a long time
since you've given albuterol to remember
exactly what that dosing is and whether
it's micrograms or milligrams that's all
there so again less cognitive overhead
for the physician less chance for errors
hopefully better patient see
order facilitators this is something
like if you're in your primary care
clinic and you order a step and you know
that you have to order liver anything
but if you're seeing 2030 patients a day
it's it's very easy to forget that so
the order facilitator example is when
you order a statin it automatically
allows you to order a liver function
test if you wish and hopefully so that
you can follow up hopefully so that if
they do have a bump and liver function
enzyme like you can catch point-of-care
alerts and reminders these can be
anything from reminders to check the
hemoglobin a1c every six months to tell
you that like as this example is saying
that you you don't need to maybe order
the metoprolol because the patient is
already on tell which because they're
both relevant information display this
can range from anything from telling you
the cost of the drug or the lab tests
for example if there's one case where an
emerge department started labeling the
point-of-care CBC tests because those
were three dollars whereas I think at
that institution the CBC lab draw the
regular lab brother wasn't a point of
care was I think of ronald lines a five
five five cents and so it cost so much
more so the residents were using the
point-of-care test because they wanted
to see who could see the most patients
in a day so when the point-of-care test
came out they just used it like crazy
and so the bill that the emerge
department got for using it was just
obviously much higher than they were
used to and so they said like please use
experiment eated for emergency cases
where you know that you need that cbc
within ten minutes for the fast GI
bleeder or whoever that may be expert
systems this at least in my mind an
example is like the PCA
order menu kind of algorithm at the VA
where at the VA in summer they found out
they're having trouble
we're interns surgical interns were
ordered incorrectly in putting PCA
orders usually way too high perhaps you
could for the non clinicians maybe
describe our Explorer apply the acronym
PCA oh sorry yeah pick like is it
patient controlled analgesia yeah so or
basically a lot of post-op patients
fisty ortho and every post-op we've at
least from what I remember from medical
school better pain control that a
patient has the quicker there they can
go home and so to kind of help with that
we've had PCAs patient controlled
analgesia and but unfortunately with
interns ordering PCA as we found out
that they were giving much too high of a
dose and so to kind of combat that or
kind of improve that or make that better
at the VA they had an expert system
which would help the the non expert the
intern to classify and place the post-op
patient into the correct PCA dosing area
so they wouldn't overdose patients
workflow support this is something as
simple as having an automatic
termination of an antibiotic order so if
it's five days of which is typical for a
pneumonia for a thorough Meissen it's an
antibiotic that you usually take if you
have pneumonia and so it would stop
after five days instead of having two
one one problem is like one if I have to
rewrite it every morning as I come in to
write these earth or my son or two I
wrote these with mice and the patient's
staying for more than five days if he
starts getting on the sixth day I don't
want that either
and so have an automatic stop water on
drugs like azithromycin for pneumonia so
then we come to another part of the talk
of like why I'm talking about always so
kind of the longest way this came about
was that
in 2014 the FDA started I don't fully
understand it's like a pre warning
morning in 2014 December they said
there's maybe an increased risk of from
bollock events there's like blood clots
heart attacks strokes which are kind of
all glows long cloth and deep vein
thrombosis if people are taking
testosterone then finally in March into
April of 2015 they finally came out with
a warning and stated that that all that
that warning is true and that all neut
all testosterone products must have be
labeled stating that there's an
increased risk for cardiovascular event
strokes and claws so the VA noted this
and decided we need to do something
about it so at the same time they wanted
to find out they think they did a little
kind of query and found out that many
veterans were receiving testosterone
even though they shouldn't be for for
various reasons many veterans were
wanting testosterone because they were
just feeling weak because they're
getting older because they had decreased
sex drive for various reasons but the
reason why this is important we'll get
to later is that you the risk benefit
ratio for testosterone isn't very good
it's very slim so testosterone is only
beneficial for a very small population
at least according to the FDA and and
also they found out that even though
they were they were first being pitocin
was being prescribed to incorrect set of
patients at the VA they were also not
getting the appropriate follow they were
not getting the appropriate lab testing
and they were not getting the
appropriate follow-up isn't to look for
signs for bad side effects for
testosterone and finally they were also
finding that there was some
inappropriate drug delivery because
because some were getting gels when they
shouldn't be getting gels some are
getting patches when they shouldn't be
any patches etc
so the VA was like well we won we have
this warning that we need to like tell
all the physicians and clinicians and
providers at the VA to make sure they
tell all their patients - incorrect
patients are getting testosterone 3
they're not getting the follow-up before
they're just not even getting the right
kind of testosterone and so they charged
the Infernus group and the order menu
group at the VA to come out improve the
appropriate use of testosterone - VA so
in starting that it was to find out like
who do we need to talk to you to
accomplish that one was you can see here
the lab the endocrinology department
other primary care physicians patients
pharmacy were the the main people that
we talked to you to try to figure out
how to do this
so and challenges of c.d.s these are the
challenges and I'm gonna go through them
and you'll see why so one is the
information isn't complete ever so when
it comes to information in medical
school and everything we moved away from
textbooks and then we move to
evidence-based medicine primarily sure
but there's again there's so much
information out there there were so many
information out there in 1976 there's
definitely much much more information
out there now there's too much and it's
and it's not complete even up to date so
an example is if I go up top to date for
I can't go for orthopedic stuff because
they just don't have very much
orthopedic stuff but if I need
background information I'll go up to
date but I when I want to actually treat
a patient and I don't know as much as I
would like to about it I'll go to
emedicine so even places that are known
to be more comprehensive more complete
and more quote-unquote up to date are
still behind at times because they're
still having to find all the literature
and go through the literature it's
ambiguous and this relates to the
testosterone in the sense that the FDA
came out with this warning but part of
it is from just papers but they're all
varying conclusive they say that there
might be an increase in cardiovascular
events there might be an increase in
stroke and there might be an increase in
having deep vein thrombosis but it's not
wholly concrete it's not like yes like
100% everyone will have a horrible
increase and it'll be really bad and the
percentage is 20% there is no number and
so it's it's very incomplete and so when
if you go to a place like national
guideline clear out so that they kind of
take all these guidelines together and
the guideline that the endocrinology
department used and I used and I think
partly what the FDA used was a guideline
from 2010 done by the endocrinology
Association of America and basically
that guideline stated that there is no
kind of solid number
that you can follow to say yes if you
have low testosterone and you get
testosterone and your test run level is
this level it's okay for you to take it
or if you have one event it's not okay
or if you have two events it's not okay
or it's okay if you have almost an event
and so they're very ambiguous guidelines
so other challenges that is very
dispersed so if you can imagine like
just it's just Manhattan like number of
hospitals there's I think it's missing
st. Luke's Roosevelt near 59th in
Columbus if you are familiar with
Manhattan and it's missing a couple
others but just this is just some of the
hospitals in New York and all them they
all have different EHRs and they all do
not communicate with each other even
though they're supposed to they still do
not yet because there was a like a New
York health exchange but it still
doesn't really work cuz no one uses it
so data is dispersed for your patients
and to find out what allergies they have
what medications they have them what
medical problems yeah and finally again
just if there's just too much
information it's you know as some people
know from going to medical school like
it's drinking out of a fire hose and to
try to compile all that information and
to make a clinical support is is very
difficult so what happened so basically
again the VA decide yes we need to have
this warning we need to follow the
guidelines and we need to have better
follow-up and have better use of the
testosterone at the VA so just to give
you details of what that entailed so in
talking to ender college department in
pharmacy in the lab that entailed making
sure that they had two testosterone
levels that were differed by 24 hours so
if you got a testosterone level on
Monday then you've got another
testosterone little bit earliest was
Tuesday they had to be at least 24 hours
apart if those two were low there's
another further album to differentiate
where the primary and secondary
happening and
that wasn't as important for prescribing
well it is important but at least not
for this problem and so if you found out
that they had true low testosterone from
hypogonadism as in because they were not
producing enough to dock testosterone
you could be on the way to maybe getting
testosterone the second part they had to
make sure that there was good follow-up
so that they had at 6 months to 3 months
there was a repeat CBC and a PSA PSA is
a prostate prostate specific antigen and
the reason that that needed to be
followed up was if you're on
testosterone it can increase your risk
of cancer and again this is more
ambiguity with guidelines there's no
they know that it's associated as far as
I know it's associated but there's not
direct evidence that yes if you have an
elevation in your PSA from taking
testosterone you are going to get cancer
and so with the ambulance it's hard but
it needs to be followed up at least and
tracked and the CBC needs to be tracked
to make sure that the hematocrit wasn't
above 54% because it can increase your
red blood cells and then finally they
need to be tracked and this is the most
ambiguous to see what are the benefits
of getting testosterone because because
of the FDA warning the VA knew that
there is some risk whether that number
is 5 1 or half a percentage increase of
having clots of strokes and
cardiovascular events we don't know how
much and they had to benefit of how much
better the patient felt on testosterone
so at three months and six months the
clinician is supposed to figure out yes
my patient is feeling I don't know like
there was there's no guideline of he's
having sex five more times a month and
so it's okay because because even though
now his stroke risk is increased to 5%
but if he's only having sex three times
a month it's not okay
and so there's no concrete way to
determine that so more ambiguity these
are just the goals I just talked about
and so what we did and I kind of
classified into the right texana me we
said medication dosing and support order
facilitators relevant information
display in some expert system so a
medication dosing support for the
testosterone menu this is the basic
testosterone menu so Oh what are your I
don't I don't think you can read it but
any first thoughts on seeing it
especially with what I've talked about
yeah there's a lot of words yeah so the
problem the kind of issue with that is
from the VA / FDA standpoint like we we
had to include the warnings if the VA
wanted about the increased
cardiovascular risk so that's a lot on
the right that's all the the risk that
they wanted us to include like the right
top corner so yes it is a lot of words
so it's like really breaking like a lot
of the 10 commandments it's not simple a
lot of words complex it's not maybe
information but again they go back to
the medication dosing another another
thought yeah also it looks like you were
struggling with it's hard to see where
the entrance and exit is of this order
pathway yes
there isn't a clear so part of what we
were thinking when we were doing that
was just that hopefully they would start
at the left top corner and then
hopefully go to the right bottom but
there isn't a clear yeah start here and
in here for medication dosing support is
just the warning that they shouldn't
exceed 400 milligrams of testosterone
for every month or every 28 days second
for order facilitator when they order
testosterone when the physician or
provider orders testosterone it
automatically generates a way for them
to order PSA and a CBC in 12 weeks to
make sure that their gun there's going
to be a lab they might not follow it up
the physician of the provider but at
least they'll be allowed for someone to
see hopefully and then relevant
information display and this is the too
many words right on the right is what
was on the right top corner which is all
the testosterone warnings and cautions
about the increased cardiovascular
events increased stroke increased
robotic events
and the bottom is the contraindications
they wanted to make sure that we had
what if you had any of these other
things you could not be placed on
testosterone things like prostate cancer
or and again this is more ambiguity
uncontrolled heart failure I'm not sure
like at what point you become
uncontrolled heart Fed does that mean
that you had an admission twice a month
or does that mean that admission three
times a month for your heart failure
it's hard to know on the left so on the
left is the only thing that I thought
was very useful um I don't know if
everyone agrees but it was it was to
kind of educate at the same time as the
the provider was putting in the orders
for trying to diagnose hypogonadism
which low testosterone it's just to tell
them that they need to be to
testosterone levels to like 24 hours
apart to diagnose hypogonadism some
expert systems and relevant information
display when you're testing for
testosterone there's a total
testosterone and free testosterone and
if you're not diabetic and you're not
obese you can be tested for total
testosterone whereas if you're a
diabetic and you're obese need to be
tested for free testosterone and that
was more of like the kind of expert
systems kind of well of me information
display as opposed to just having the
total testosterone just the free so that
the provider knows which one to pick for
their patient
so depending on the it is just going
live it's just online depending on the
data collected because you know we need
to test not test study the
implementation to see whether it
actually did improve like does it make
it worse or more people now getting
testosterone who really don't need
testosterone because we put it all in
one page it did improve the appropriate
use of testosterone for VA patients
hopefully we'll be to study that with
data will collect over the next months
and again like whence for other
revisions and say other problems with
like when when should we revise this
because it's so ambiguous because
there's so information so much
information even if you look at the idea
of it going live this fall kind of the
impetus started in 2014 December so it's
already like a year later and that it's
being implemented so on some level you
could say the information is a year old
and so then how often how soon should we
be revising this for information that's
always going to be incomplete and almost
always ambiguous I don't know if there's
anyone have any comments on the
ambiguity question
think about it okay I don't have a
button sorry is it there's a lot of name
acuity like you said but I my limited
experience it'll almost be helpful to
like have citations in there to say like
this is where this ambiguity comes from
like these are contraindications they
can kind of soft contradictions you know
I mean does that make sense yeah because
otherwise you're just taking the
computer word for it yeah and and
there's a lot of decision-making that's
being taken away from yeah no and then
oh you're you're basically your comment
was that you you like what you're seeing
except that you wish that there was a
citation for the concert education is
for the guidelines and for their
recommendations or reasons yeah and so
no I like the citations because I've
seen other order manual citations but
the problem was that there were already
too many words that like I kind of maybe
it was it was it was it was at least at
that point it was just there's so many
words that like if I could not have more
words it was yeah yeah but I definitely
there's also a lot of empty white space
in that menu yeah yeah to be fair and
and I'd like to actually here maybe in
he'll give you give it a little bit more
an explanation or insight into some of
the decisions he made because I I have a
little I know enough to know that the
requirements he was furnished or at
least the content that was furnished to
and by the department that in chronology
looked quite a bit different than this
so he had to go through a lot of steps
to translate pages of material into
something that was consumer-ready
at the point of care and so aside from
the fact that he was getting content
that had to be re recompiled in an in a
usable way for the computer he also I
personally working at the VA I like the
CPS system and I think it's very good
but nevertheless I also concede that the
menus themselves impose a lot of design
constraints for example you can't
your font you can't change the font size
you can't change the color of the menus
there's not a lot of branching decision
logic so he also had to contend with
some of that so what you're looking at
are it looks like a number of
compromises that you know how to make
between what the stakeholders wanted
what would make sense as an
implementation and what design
constraints were imposed by the health
record system maybe maybe you want to
comment about that because I know a lot
went through your head going from what
you received from stakeholders to what
we see on screen guess some things there
was definitely a lot more they wanted in
the menu and put in the menu because it
was about four pages four pages of
single spaced reasoning and logic that
they thought was very important and so
part of it was how do I get that in
there at the same time as not like
overburdening and it's still kind of a
lot of words yeah as if for the white
space I yeah I think there's I think
it's just like could say it's like an
inline was a command-line interface so
you got we have to type in each line of
like print like printf like oh yeah this
line and then print this line it's like
so it's just the way kind of it is you
can't graphically make it that much more
pretty it's not in CPRS I think in other
things it can be done and came doing
really well and yeah but yeah we talked
about expert system so based on what you
said it doesn't sound like expert system
it's expert support system and the
question was yeah do you know any other
so it's not an expert system in the I
think maybe you're thinking about like
an expert system as in like it takes
actual patient data and then takes the
evidence and then gives you like a
diagnosis or a drug is that what you're
thinking yeah
no no so yeah so he's not yeah he's not
talking about rights not talking about
that kind of experts isn't he just means
an expert system is as it's taken some
of the thinking away from you so you
don't have to think about how to do a
transfusion like so you don't have to
have been think that oh I have a GI
bleeder whose hemoglobin is seven but he
seemed likely stable but he's a little
tachy so you don't have to like go
through all those things it so that the
EHR will tell you he's tachy and
hypotensive and Hebron is seven point
five in our system you need to be
transfused and just it just tells you
that that I think that's the more kind
of expert system it's not like the I
don't it's not as complex as what you're
thinking about it's it's more of a
taxonomy expert system that he's using
vocabulary not like big world expert
system a I like taking real-time data
and like giving you these great answers
one day I hope to have that but nobody
has that right now if I might say you
know it's an interesting comment
I think we're rights coming from ash and
right and a number of others and frankly
a camp that I also tend to occupies we
tend to use a larger working definition
for expert systems when you're talking
about I think you're getting to the
point that some expert systems are what
we used to call the Oracle systems you
put information into a computer and in
return you get some sort of answer as
though all of the thinking has been done
essentially behind the curtain and while
Oracle systems are still out there and
and by the way they're their flavors of
that I know that one of them probably
the most though highly celebrated of
sort of historical systems and that that
generation of sort of decision support
was what was developed at Intermountain
health care system and their health
system so essentially every time you see
a patient in the ER in Salt Lake and you
start inputting information into that
health record system it was generating
content that would help sort of drive
the decision making oh this patient
appears to be infarct that you need to
move them to a cardiac care step-down
unit so it was taking a lot of that
improve a lot of those calculation steps
off of your out of your responsibility
and out of your hands and placing us or
behind the curtain
the interesting thing though is that
there they're also with some backlash to
Oracle systems and whether or not you
know by hiding or suppressing some of
that content whether or not actually
you're getting buy-in from your
clinicians and by and large that's
actually something we still struggle
with today is the more you essentially
suppress or conceal a lot of that expert
thinking sometimes you'll actually see a
rather visceral response to your
end-users oftentimes clinicians don't
like to think that the computer cannot
think that I myself am a clinician I'm a
little bit unsettled by that prospect
that maybe there's a watson out there
that can do a better job and what I've
trained my whole life to do now in Italy
that's somewhat emotional but so with
that in mind a lot of what we do say at
the VA and a lot of expert systems
rather than actually running or or
crunching the data behind the scenes we
conceptualize expert systems as how do
you represent data or in a schema that
actually is emblematic of the way an
expert thinks novices they tend to have
information just sort of scattered or
distribute whereas experts tend to
consolidate things into very
sophisticated schemas and so arguably if
you think of expert systems in a in a
larger framework much as the way Adam
Wright is doing you can argue that some
of what inho is done here is actually
tried to model expert thinking how does
an expert endocrinologist approach the
problem of potential hypogonadism and is
there as a stepwise approach he's tried
to do that here with him again
admittedly the decidedly strong
constraints of this particular clinical
environment on the blue yeah it's August
I have a urology question so it's one
that we didn't get to ask when we were
doing this was what is there a PSA
cutoff at six months or three months
that you like
a number like there's no definite number
that okay approach with your prop
yeah
yeah that's basically
or another scintillating on informatics
lecture from dr. Kim and I definitely
encourage anybody that has further
questions to please join him down front
and again I appreciate everybody
attending today and look forward to
seeing you next time and don't forget if
you're interested in climbing the CME
credit that will be available please
contact Lynch WAP thank you so much